since the Communist Party came to power
in 1949 China has been cracking down on
the we gus' a Muslim ethnic minority so
what's at stake besides China's national
unity resources Wiggins live in Xinjiang
which has an estimated one third of
China's natural gas and oil reserves and
it's rich really rich in mineral
resources Chang Jiang also produces a
lot of cotton 60% of China's output and
the last major resource space shinjang
is one sixth of China's total area but
less than one percent of China's
population lives there some officials
see shinjang as part of a solution to
China's overcrowding problem so if it
wasn't for all this would China still
care about its so-called weaker problem
want more download the aj+ mobile app
and join the conversation
available in your app store now